mohamed al fayed à paris pour être
entendu par le juge d'instruction le
père du compagnon de diana n'est pas
convaincu par la thèse de l'accident il
mène sa propre enquête parallèle
conduite sous influence de la drogue le
phénomène n'est plus marginal en france
un projet de loi pourrait officialiser
ce délit comme il existe la conduite en
état d'ivresse journée nationale de la
grande vieillesse les services à
domicile se multiplient pour permettre
de retarder l'entrée en maison de
retraite nations unies s'inquiètent de
l'arrivée des mafias russes dans le
trafic de drogue la russie où le nombre
de drogués s'est multiplié en quelques
années
franck est dans ce journal à moins de
100 jours du coup d'envoi de la coupe du
monde de football les gadgets arrivent
sur le marché la mascotte footix vient
de loin chine où elle est fabriquée à
des millions d'exemplaires à monsieur
bonsoir c'est dans la nuit du 30 août
dernier que le monde stupéfait apprenait
la nouvelle celle que tous les magazines
appelait la princesse des coeurs lady
diana avaient trouvé la mort dans un
accident de la circulation à paris avec
son compagnon dodi al fayed
sept mois plus tard les conditions
exactes de l'accident ne sont toujours
pas éclaircies et les auditions se
poursuivent aujourd'hui
sept mois après les faits mohamed al
fayed le père de dodi est venu à paris
pour y être entendu par le juge
d'instruction
entre-temps mohamed al fayed a déclaré à
plusieurs reprises qu'il ne croyait pas
à la thèse de l'accident mais plutôt
complot visant à empêcher son fils
d'épouser un membre de la famille royale
britannique va les ermites guillaume
poudre à sa sortie du ritz mohamed al
fayed ne fuit pas les caméras
bien au contraire un mois jour pour jour
après avoir déclaré dans la presse qu'il
était persuadé que l'accident du pont de
l'alma était un complot le père de dodi
al fayed était convoquée à sa demande
par les juges d'instruction chargés de
l'enquêté
c'est la première fois que mohamed al
fayed rencontre les magistrats français
à sa sortie mohamed al fayed est ému
mais garde le sourire
l'objet essentiel de cette entrevue
fêtait de rendre compte à monsieur payet
les résultats actuels de l'enquète et
plus permettent de remercier tous ceux
qui ont participé à l'instruction
mohamed al fayed n'a été entendu qu'en
tant que parent de victime et non en
tant que propriétaire du ritz et donc
indirectement employeur du chauffeur de
la mercedes henri paul dont les analyses
démontrent qu'il avait bu une situation
un peu délicate pour le milliardaire
égyptien qui depuis le début même sa
propre enquête avec l'aide d'un ex
patron de la brigade criminelle
pierre ottavioli aujourd'hui devenu
détective privé
une initiative qui ne plaît pas
forcément aux enquêteurs français
mohamed al fayed a aujourd'hui tenu à
déclarer sa totale confiance en ces
mêmes enquêteurs tout en précisant qu'il
n'écartait aucune hypothèse quant aux
causes de l'accident et qu'il
continuerait à demander des
investigations supplémentaires
on ne sait pas bien entendu ce que
mohamed al fayed et le juge
d'instruction se sont dit cet après-midi
et notamment s'il a bel et bien été
question de l'éventualité d'un complot
pour mieux comprendre l'état d'esprit de
mohamed al-fayed il faut s'intéresser à
sa personnalité à ces difficultés pour
s'intégrer à la bonne société anglaise
et cela malgré ces milliards londres
etienne leenhardt
c'est l'histoire d'un homme riche très
riche et qui malgré tous ses milliards
et tous ses efforts n'a toujours pas
obtenu ce qu'ils réclament depuis trente
ans un passeport britannique
mohamed al fayed et égyptiens mais il ne
rêve que d'une chose devenir anglais et
ce droit là les gouvernements
britanniques successifs le lui ont
toujours refusé des doutes sur l'origine
de sa fortune une réputation sulfureuse
d'hommes d'affaires sans scrupules
au royaume des bonnes manières
l'establishment le traite en paria et al
fayed s'en offusque
pensez vous que ce soit juste que les
autorités me refuse de devenir citoyen
sa majesté moi qui ai donné du travail à
des milliers de gens et qu'ils aient
quatre enfants britanniques avaient en
effet al fayed pour parvenir à ses fins
n'a jamais lésiné sur les moyens
ils achètent harrods le lendemain ou
presque un club de football londonien
qu'il entend mener au firmament du
championnat britannique à l'été 90 est
la révélation publique d'une liaison
entre son fils dodi et la princesse de
galles sonne comme une victoire de plus
que l'accident du pont de l'alma va
transformer en tragédie
le deuil passé mohamed al fayed n'a de
cesse de dénoncer un complot organisé
sur le thème de l'amour impossible entre
le fils d'un homme d'affaires égyptien
et la mère du futur roi d'angleterre
des accusations qui exaspère l'opinion
britannique sa lourde insistance à
répétait que ce n'est pas un accident
qui a coûté la vie à diana et dodi
choque tout le monde
non seulement les journalistes mais
aussi l'homme de la rue qui ne veut pas
croire à toutes ces thèses de
conspiration la question reste ainsi
posé que cherche donc mohamed al fayed
qui en quelques déclarations s'est une
nouvelle fois mis à dos la famille
royale la presse et l'opinion d'un pays
qui n'est pas tout à fait le sien au
début du mois de février un avion de
l'armée américaine souvenez-vous
promeneurs provoqué la mort de 20
personnes en coupant le câble d'un
téléphérique dans le nord de l'italie
après bien des tergiversations le
commandement américain reconnaît que
l'équipage de l'avion est fautif que
l'appareil volait trop vite et trop bas
300 mètres du sol au lieu de six en cinq
ans 81 et r risque la cour martiale
la justice française va-t-elle instaurer
une loi réprimant la conduite après
consommation de drogue comme il existe
déjà un délit de conduite en état
d'ivresse pour la première fois un
tribunal correctionnelle à poitiers
va juger demain deux jeunes
automobilistes qui ont mis la vie de
plusieurs personnes en danger alors
qu'il venait de consommer du cannabis
ce phénomène n'est plus marginal donc
les gendarmes la justice se trouve tous
les jours presque confrontés à ce type
d'infraction sans pouvoir le sanctionner
sauf en cas d'accident le gouvernement
prévoit d'ailleurs d'intégrer ce délit
dans un projet de loi actuellement en
préparation reportage matuchet philippe
visseyrias qu'outre un accident mortel
l'alcootest et systématique mais demain
vous devrez en plus subir un contrôle
urinaire pour rechercher la présence de
drogue
une loi est en préparation elle devrait
être votée au printemps
l'alcool est en cause dans 30 % des
accidents mortels mais pour la drogue on
ne sait pas et c'est pour ça qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir cette connaissance
statistique qui ne peut se faire qu'à
partir de dépistage et la loi prévoit
que ces dépistages ne seront fait
d'ailleurs qu'en cas d'accident mortel
cela nous donnera une connaissance du
phénomène et permettra de voir s'il est
utile de prendre telle ou telle autre
mesure par la suite un dépistage mais
pas encore de nouvelles sanctions
légales
pourtant pour ce médecin aucun doute la
drogue dans à remplacer l'alcool dans 15
% des accidents graves cannabis ecstasy
sont en cause
il y à des catégories entières de jeunes
qui maintenant ne recourent plus à
l'alcool mais recourt à l'ecstasy au
cannabis souvent associés et qui cherche
une défonce samedi soir avec ce type de
produit plutôt qu'à l'alcool pour
mesurer les effets de la drogue les
américains ont mis leurs meilleurs
pilotes dans des simulateurs de vol une
heure après avoir fumé du cannabis
l'avion a bien atterri mais à vingt
mètres de la piste
une étude menée en france sur les
accidents de moto donne des résultats
sans équivoque
c'était une étude qui a porté sur tous
les motards accueilli à l'institut de
médecine légale qui étaient mortes dans
suite d'incidents circulation et on a pu
mettre en évidence que sur ces 35 cas
dans 25% des cas il y avait des produits
hallucinogènes des stupéfiants demain
des policiers français recevront
peut-être cette formation test d'
équilibre contrôle de la rétine aux
états unis repéré un conducteur sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants n'est plus un
secret
l'europe est à un grand dessein
politique mais c'est également une série
de décisions que certains jugent par
trop tatillonne dernier exemple en date
la commission de bruxelles propose de
nouvelles normes plus sévères pour
assurer le bien-être des poules
pondeuses élevés en batterie
une décision dont les conséquences
économiques sont jugées très graves par
les éleveurs bretons notamment reportage
ligne et sio michel hiver les apparences
sont trompeuses
avec vingt mille volailles l'élevage de
poules pondeuses de christian le pas
d'un mais qu'une modeste exploitation
une bretagne qui à elles seules fournit
près de la moitié des 13 milliards veut
produit chaque année en france
pourtant les directives de bruxelles qui
veut réduire le nombre de poules par
cage ou augmenter la taille de ses cages
risque d'avoir de sérieuses conséquences
sur son activité
christian a déjà fait ses comptes en
abaissant
nombre de foot c'est comme du grand de
revenus
- pour moi j'essaie beat feuz qui rend
revenu global qui fait combien à peu
près 120 milles
ça fait à peu près 40% vaut quoi vous en
30 ans pour sans droits un coup dur pour
les aviculteurs donc alors qu'il n'est
même pas sûr que cette mesure voulue par
les anglais uniquement destiné à assurer
le bien-être des poules traits d'une
quelconque efficacité
ces jeunes chercheuses s'apprête à
soutenir sa thèse sur les poules
justement pendant trois ans elle à
observer leur comportement dans
différents types de cages sa conclusion
agrandir les cages est loin de m'avoir
que des avantages
nous avons observé dans des différences
significatives dans les grandes cages
avec ou sans perchoir avec cinq des
fréquences de mortalité dû au
cannibalisme beaucoup plus
significativement plus importante ce qui
est un aspect très négatif en fait d'eux
des recommandations de la communauté
européenne
plus d espace nommé leur donne pas
forcément le bien-être des poules mais
réduit à coup sûr la compétitivité des
élevages car d'autres pays non pas des
normes aussi contraignant les etats-unis
qui sont aujourd'hui le deuxième
producteur mondial de f1 ont des
conditions d'intensification de la
production qui sont beaucoup plus
draconiennes que ce qui est fait en
europe
en europe on a 450 centimètres carrés
par poule où les états unis sont 350
voire 300 cm carré par poule comment
être compétitif
si les conditions de production ne sont
pas les mêmes toute la question est donc
de savoir si le consommateur est prêt
demain à payer plus cher ses yeux pour
le sol bien-être de la poule qu'il a
pondu c'est aujourd'hui la journée de la
grande vieillesse en france une
expression qui n'est pas forcément très
heureuse mais qui dit bien ce qu'elle
veut dire les français vivent de plus en
plus vieux et là c'est heureux et
retarde au maximum leur entrée dans les
maisons de retraite pour ce faire toute
une série de services sont à leur
disposition services médicaux services
de toutes sortes marié delbono
jean-louis melun reportage jaminet
ménagères car elle garde à domicile
patricia coordinatrice des soins à
domicile
béatrice est soignants bagheri pour
rester chez soi à 102 ans il faut de
l'aide
sept personnes ont tous occupent de
marguerite jour et nuit des services qui
lui coûte environ 12 mille francs par
mois
les tarifs sont calculées en fonction
des ressources vous n'êtes jamais tout
seul
en france près de 4 millions de
personnes ont plus de 75 ans cinq cent
mille d'entre elles restent à la maison
oui et puis des structures sanitaires et
médicales mises en place 365 jours par
an pour maintenir les personnes âgées
dans leur univers le plus longtemps
possible
autre exemple la livraison des repas à
domicile ils sont cuisinés dans la
maison de retraite est porté par des
agents communaux comme agnès qui en
livre 50 par jour pour 38 francs le
repas c'est un service indispensable
pour albert et marie jeanne et si vous
aviez pas ces services là vous pensez
vous
hors hôpital ou alors la maison de
retraite de l'infirmière à l'aide
soignante de l'aide ménagère à la mise
en place de transports adaptés
il existe en france environ 15 cents
services différents pour maintenir dans
les meilleures conditions possibles les
personnes âgées chez elles à dole dans
le jura démantèlement d'un réseau
pédophile sur internet trente et une
personnes dont cinq mineurs ont été
interpellés dans toute la france le
réseau proposait des photos
pornographiques notamment les enquêteurs
ont également recensé environ 150
utilisateurs du sites installés à
l'étranger au procès de maurice papon à
bordeaux les plaidoiries des parties
civiles se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas forcément après la demande de peine
mesurées de la part de m arno klarsfeld
aujourd'hui au nom du consistoire
israélite m jacubowicz lui a au
contraire demandé la peine maximum pour
maurice papon françois privat philippe
dumas l'émotion d'alain jacques eu beau
fixe sur un véritable le ton de
procureur l'avocat vient de lancer à la
cour vous juger pour l'humanité
votre verdict doit aller au delà de la
perpétuité il doit s'inscrire dans
l'éternité
comment imaginer qu'un criminel contre
l'humanité puisse être condamné à autre
chose que la peine la plus importante
comment est ce que demain dans une cour
d'assises on pourra condamner un
criminel à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité si un criminel contre
l'humanité n'est pas condamné à cette
peine
c'est un problème de société c'est un
problème de valeurs c'est pas un
problème de droit ce qu'ils demandent
les uns et les autres c'est qu'ils
soient condamnés à mort c'est à dire à
mourir en prison parce que dix ans à
perpétuité à son âge c'est rigolote pas
la même chose
et quand elle lui il n'y a qu'une
alternative la liberté ou perpétuité
alain jacubowicz a également évoqué des
articles de presse de 1942 qui décrivent
les camps d'extermination
pour l'avocat maurice papon savez
forcément y'a des strates successives
qui vont effectivement de la prise de la
conscience jusqu'à une connaissance une
connaissance évidente parce que c'est
vrai joly dit et ça fait si mal de le
dire tout le monde
les zetas avaient les résistances avait
tout le monde savait et tout le monde
vous l'ignorez maurice papon n'a pas
semblé écouter un mot de la plaidoirie
d' alain jacubowicz pendant plus de deux
heures il a écrit et feuilleté de
nombreux dossiers remue-ménage dans un
quartier de nice aujourd'hui la police a
même bouclé une rue dans laquelle
étaient installés jusqu'à l'été dernier
un cabinet de radiologie depuis un taux
de radioactivité anormalement élevés ont
été mesurées avec des risques potentiels
pour les habitants du voisinage des
vérifications sont actuellement en cours
quel que soit le résultat de dimanche
soir cette campagne pour les élections
régionales aura permis aux français de
découvrir le nouvel homme fort de la
majorité françois hollande premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste considéré
il ya quelques mois encore comme la
courroie de transmission de lionel
jospin il a acquis des
or mais son indépendance reportage album
nicosie nathalie gallet françois
hollande a remporté la première manche
quel que soit le résultat du scrutin
dimanche
le voilà désormais reconnue sur son
petit nuage
multipliant les déplacements comme ici à
limoges c'est lui qui incarne la
campagne des socialistes est lui même
s'il s'en défend qui récoltera le
dividende d'une victoire annoncée
grâce à lionel jospin si on perd ça
raconte du parti social en un mois il
aura promené son allure jovial dans
toutes les régions de visite éclair en
déjeuner d'élus si le personnage est
tout en rondeur
il ne perd jamais de vue son objectif
double asseoir durablement son autorité
sur le ps mais aussi s'affirmer aux yeux
du grand public comme le véritable
adversaire des leaders de la droite
qui va de ville en ville en avion et on
nous dit même en hélicoptère car c'est
le moyen de transport préféré du rpr
l'hélicoptère tantôt pour des places et
s'est dirigé en tantôt pour aller
chercher des juges dans l'himalaya
alors au soir de cette campagne
françois hollande a surtout su expliquer
l'intérêt des listes gauche plurielle
non c'est pas le mieux beaucoup d'élus
pour les verts et le pc certes mais les
présidents de région seront te presque
toujours issus du ps 5 8 10 12 peut-être
il en rosit de plaisir
alors hier soir françois hollande s'est
offert une petite pause une soirée à
londres avec les premiers secrétaires
des partis socialistes européens
l'occasion d'expliquer les subtilités de
la politique française aux anglais mais
l'occasion aussi de tisser des liens
toujours avec le sourire il explique que
cela pourra servir un jour du côté de
l'opposition il est apparu au fil de
cette campagne que certains membres du
rpr reprocher à leurs collègues de l'udf
qui pourtant président la majorité des
conseils régionaux en france d'assurer
en quelque sorte le service minimum
reproche que n'accepte pas l'un des
chefs de file de l'udf françois bayrou
reportage véronique saint-élie philippe
dur pour ces régionales jusqu'ici
enquêtés sont beaucoup d'engagement mais
le ton monte on a vérifié dix fois et
spécialement à chaque dernières
élections que le climat se modifier dans
les derniers jours et quelquefois les
dernières heures nous soyons comme une
émission de radio pour un exercice de
pédagogie appliquer consciencieusement
françois bayrou fait campagne aux mêmes
s'ils vont le chef de force démocrate il
s'agit surtout d'un exercice obligé les
pronostics de l'ordinateur portable sont
mauvais et la voix de l'udf ces
dernières semaines est restée plutôt
discrète
même si françois bayrou s'est appliqué à
multiplier les meetings dans la dernière
ligne droite dans le tour de france
passe dans les pyrénées
il ya toujours un monsieur généralement
un peu ventripotent assis dans un col au
bord de la route sur un pliant et qui
crient quand les coureurs passent ils
pédalent feignants et j'ai toujours
pensé ça quand on voit les critiques
s'abattre sur les hommes politiques en
dix ans et pourquoi vous en faites pas
plus pourquoi vous n'êtes pas encore
plus sur le terrain mais c'est au siège
de son parti à paris que françois bayrou
prépare déjà l'après régionales une
modernité affichée et à pragmatisme
revendiqué si les résultats de dimanche
sont mauvais l'ambitieux patron de force
démocrate rêve tout d'une réorganisation
de nos positions dans l'expérience de la
gauche il ya un point qui désormais
marquera les français c'est qu'elle est
plurielle et il faut que nous sachions
aussi être plurielle on croyait pourtant
l'opposition déjà uni sur l'essentiel et
diverses aussi alors ce souhait d'une
sorte de confédération claqué sur
l'exemple de la gauche qui laisse rêveur
un pourcentage positif dans les
statistiques sur les effectifs salariés
en france dans les secteurs privé et
concurrentiel hors fonction publique
donc en france en 1997 d'années s'est
terminée sur un total de 13 millions
quatre cent quatre-vingt mille sept
cents salariés soit une augmentation de
1,2 pour cent par rapport à l'année
précédente
un bon chiffre encore pour renault le
constructeur automobile français annonce
un bénéfice de cinq milliards et demi de
francs l'an dernier après une perte
équivalente c'était en 96
la société va proposer des dividendes à
ses actionnaires
toute la gamme s'est bien vendu et
notamment la nouvelle scénique la grève
des sapeurs pompiers des aéroports de
roissy et d'orly et terminer un accord a
été conclu ce matin avec la direction
des deux aéroports parisiens le trafic a
repris normalement
c'est un homme d'affaires vraiment pas
comme les autres qui de passage à paris
ces beignets ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie dans une des fontaines de
la place de la concorde pour faire
parler de son entreprise il est anglais
il s'appelle richard branson il a 47 ans
et sa manière à lui d'assurer la
promotion de son empire fondé sur une
maison de disques le tourisme et
l'aviation commerciale
et aujourd'hui de celui des boissons
pétillantes est vraiment très
particulière frédéric crotales un look
at you c'est la douzième fortunes de
grande-bretagne 132 société dix mille
employés dans le monde entier pour
vendre son vers jean paul à paris
richard branson se déguise en homme
grenouille à hong kong en mandarin et la
presse publie régulièrement des photos
provocatrices son empire s'infiltre dans
tous les secteurs de l'économie et il
rechigne jamais à payer de sa personne
pour qu'on parle de lui
les gens travaillent dur dans mon groupe
et ce nouveau projet n'est pas facile
alors s'il faut faire des choses
stupides faut qu'on parle de nous et
bien je fais des choses stupides je n'ai
pas envie de grandir
on m'accuse parfois d'avoir un caractère
à la peter pan je ne sais pas si c'est
vrai mais en tout cas je ne veux pas
grandi
cet ancien hippie a des allures de rock
star il signe des autographes et joue de
la poignée de main comme un homme
politique en campagne
mais derrière son sourire permanent
derrière sa timidité se cache en fait un
redoutable homme d'affaires
pragmatique la cantonade
volontaire et continua univers je peux
vous dire qu'il va lâche pas il réussit
plutôt bien avec sa compagnie aérienne
il possède aujourd'hui 17 appareils et
agace british airways
mais richard bronson connaît des soucis
avec la partie britannique d'eurostar et
ses deux compagnies train il est
gourmand peut être un peu trop et ce que
l'on reproche à ce patron atypique et
fonceur c'est l'opacité financière qui
entoure les comptes de ces sociétés
il cherche des fonds d'investissement
sur le marché les banques et ça depuis
longtemps
alors il doit sortir dans la lumière il
devrait expliquer les choses plus
clairement il faut qu'il suive les
règles du jeu plus qu'avant ces attaques
et ces critiques de plus en plus
pressante font perdre à richard branson
son sens de l'humour
certains de mes concurrents ont payé
très cher les spécialistes les relations
publiques pour salir vers jean
bouilloire déstabiliser virgin ce serait
la preuve que ce groupe dérange vraiment
en quelques mois d'existence
il a déjà réussi à grignoter quelques
parts de marché à pepsi cola
dans un récent rapport
les nations unies s'inquiétait du
renforcement des filières de la drogue
au travers des pays de l'ex union
soviétique l'augmentation de la
consommation de drogues n'épargnant pas
au passage la russie où le phénomène
était encore inconnu il ya quatre ou
cinq ans à peine aujourd'hui il est
malheureusement bien réel
les différentes mafias du pays
commencent à s'y intéresser
c'est notre enquête de ce soir gilles
rabin jean françois roth ces images
d'une arrestation en flagrant délit de
petit chef mafieux ont été tournées et
vendu tel quel par la milice de mosman
la brutalité qu'elle montre est un aveu
d'impuissance
la police russe a pris l'habitude de
compenser par la violence son manque de
moyens d'investigation et son manque de
savoir faire face à la drogue
elle est désarmée ironie de l'histoire
après la chute de gorbatchev les rues
autour de la loubianka le siège de l'ex
kgb était devenue le quartier des
drogues est aujourd'hui de la drogue
on en trouve partout à moscou et de
toutes sortes n'importe quelle pièce au
coin de n'importe quelle rue peut cacher
de l'héroïne de la cocaïne des drogues
chimiques ou comme ici le l'opium
il y a deux millions de drogués recensés
en russie depuis quelques mois c'est une
véritable explosion
silencieux à moscou il ya seulement
trois ans l'héroïne n'existait pas une
chanson danse aujourd'hui nous avons une
explosion de délinquance il ya les
rouilles à moscou à l'entrée des boîtes
de nuit on contrôler l'âge des clientes
mais aussi le contenu de leurs sacs et
même si le gorille de l'entrée est due
au bon enfant ce qu'il surprend avec de
la drogue
il les livre à la police depuis un an et
demi le problème s'est aggravé et on a
remarqué que les consommateurs de drogue
sont de plus en plus jeunes
parmi ceux qui viennent ici les drogués
sont des étudiants des écoles
supérieures de moscou
la boîte de nuit qui s'appelle le ghana
rappaz mais organise ce jour là une
soirée filles réservé aux étudiants des
grandes écoles
la drogue est interdite mais la bière et
gratuit on essaie d'intéresser les gens
à d'autres choses comme la musique ou
cette soirée est réservée aux filles
pour qu'elles s'amusent sans drogue sans
drogue peut-être sans limite sûrement
aux canards affamés les clientes sont
déchaînés en russie les barrières
morales ont sauté avec la fin du
totalitarisme et les jeunes volent tout
essayé l'alcool le sexe et la drogue
l'utilisation des drogues et des
psychotropes comme le lsd ecstasy et
s'est fait désormais partie de la sous
culture de la jeunesse omj la nouvelle
russie s'inquiète parce qu'elle est
touché à la tête et nouveau drogués sont
d'abord des enfants de la nouvelle
bourgeoisie russe drogue de riches broc
dépôt image de la police ce taudis
cacher un laboratoire clandestin
on y fabriquait latchoumaya
littéralement la noir à jus d'opium
préparé dans des bassines les seringues
sont remplies directement à la bassine
quand la bassine et contaminer toutes
les seringues leçon
la noire fait des ravages la dose vaut
un dollar s'ils feront c'est la drogue
la moins chère du mois d'avril un public
et le premier ministre sont aujourd'hui
à londres pour une réunion destinée à
examiner les candidatures des pays qui
désirent entrer dans l'union européenne
sont au nombre de onze la turquie ont
été écartés contre l'avis de la france
sous la pression de pays comme la grèce
ou de l'allemagne qui dénonce notamment
la violation des droits de l'homme dans
ce pays ou bien la lutte contre la
minorité kurde et sûrs que ne cachent
pas leur décision et leur amertume
reportage philippe rochot jean-louis
leur monde
les gratte ciel domine les mosquées dans
le quartier des affaires d'istanbul pour
les turcs
c'est le signe que leur pays était digne
de rentrer dans l'europe les hommes
d'affaires ressemble au nôtre et
communique avec notre continent alors le
refus de l'union européenne d'accepter
la turquie en son sein et vécu ici comme
une claque politique
le patron des patrons turc qui parle au
nom d'emile société qu'il représente
avait placé tous ses espoirs dans
l'entrée de la turquie dans l'union
européenne
lépine stamm ans claudia schmied entrer
dans l'europe
ça signifie la démocratie est pour nous
la richesse et surtout la chance de
faire partie d'une société qui s'est
montrée supérieure à celle de tous les
autres pays du monde en termes de
démocratie et de justice sociale
et quand il évoque l'europe l'homme sait
de quoi il parle
son entreprise textile qui emploie 1800
salariés exporte déjà les trois quarts
de ses produits vers notre continent
depuis la mise en place de l'union
douanière en 96 les barrières
économiques sont pratiquement tombées
reste les barrières politiques et
surtout psychologique ces ouvriers ont
une conscience européenne être exclue de
l'europe est pour eux une humiliation la
turquie mérité d'entrer dans l'union
européenne
car nous sommes déjà tournés vers
l'europe ce refus est une perte surtout
pour l'europe qui doit rectifier cela à
tous les niveaux les turcs eux sont
conscients que leur pays doit régler ses
problèmes de droits de l'homme
mais les gens estiment au contraire
qu'il fallait intégrer la turquie à
l'europe pour l'aider à avancer vers
plus de démocratie
l'union européenne a pris un peu le
risque de bisous à l'est la turquie sur
le plan international et surtout en ce
qui concerne les investissements
étrangers
mais c'est oublier que des pays comme la
grèce ont freiné des quatre fers pour
empêcher la turquie d'entrer dans
l'union européenne obligeant ainsi ce
pays charnière entre l'europe et l'asie
à se tourner un peu plus vers l'amérique
et la russie
occasion toujours de cette rencontre de
londres aujourd'hui le président jacques
chirac a déclaré qu'il opposerait le
veto de la france à l'annoncé faite par
l'un des commissaires européens leon
brittan de créer une vaste zone de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et les
etats unis dans l'état actuel des choses
il n'en est pas question a dit jacques
chirac
peut-être une issue à la crise du kosovo
il faut encore attendre bien entendu
mais belgrade qui continue de refuser
toute ingérence internationale accepte
d'accorder une autonomie très large à la
province un statut dont elle bénéficié
dans le passé on est à moins de 100
jours de la coupe du monde de football
et tous les gadgets qui seront vendus à
l'occasion de cette manifestation
commence à arriver sur le marché pour
certains comme le fameux footix mascotte
de la coupe du monde
ils viennent de très loin de chine très
exactement reportage isabelle bechler
tristan le droit quand marcel colombet
atterit assia même c'est son premier
voyage en chine
il représente une entreprise française
spécialisée dans le gadget
flanqué de son intermédiaire et d'un
traducteur il se rend à l' usine qui
doit fabriquer des mascottes officielles
pour le mondial 98
le directeur de l'usiné qui fabriquera
un footix chanteur et lumineux l'attend
premier contact de visu après un an de
négociations par fax et téléphone
un soc gen tek le général colombet nous
en donnera l'ordre
nous marchons comme un seul homme
ah ah
le petit coq contient un interrupteur
pile puce il faut le moule et le coller
le pont c'est le partir le peindre une
dizaine de gestes différents sont
effectués sur le gallinacé cocardier
marcel colombet est là pour en vérifier
la qualité d'électronique ya pas de
problème le moule n'y a pas de problème
alors ma porte le ballon
y'a pas prendre la mer également les
voyait ballack
mon travail n'est vraiment le travail
d'acteur c'est très bien ça va sur le
problème le plus important pour nous
c'est les délais on est d'accord surtout
maintenant mais si on doit faire deux à
trois millions de mascotte en deux mois
c'est vraiment juste un aj moins 100 il
semble que cette main d'oeuvre peu
qualifiée très consciencieuse puisse
tenir le pari le footix chanteur sortira
entre 5 et 6 francs de lusine de tin
tient alors que des ouvriers européens
auraient porté son prix de revient à
près de 30 francs pièce mais au fait qui
est footix vous savez nous les ouvriers
on n'a pas trop le temps de s'intéresser
à ces choses là moi j'ai pas trop
regarder le foot à la télé je préfère
les chanteurs à la mode c'est le code
qui porte bonheur
la mascotte de la coupe du monde de foot
un ouvrier de la campagne chinoise gagné
en moyenne 450 francs par mois
il sera facile d'en recruter trois fois
au temps du jour au lendemain si la
commande définitive atteint les sommets
espérés par la partie chinoise
le volume de la commande est justement
ce qui se négocie en ce moment pied à
pied marcel colombet doit être
intraitable sur le prix tout en
commandant une quantité moindre faire
accepter des paliers au fournisseur
chinois
c'est tout le problème mais une fois
signé le plus important c'est la
confiance
quand la confiance est établie on peut
travailler ensemble sans la moindre
réserve
photo x
try to victory magnifique ue la course
cycliste paris-nice conséquence du
mauvais temps le départ prévu à cusset
ce matin dû être déplacé d'une
cinquantaine de kilomètres pour chutes
de neige abondantes à l'arrivée au col
de la république c'est le maillot blanc
de leader donc le belge frank
vandenbroucke qui l'a emporté au
classement général il continue de
devancer laurent jalabert de 44 secondes
le groupe phénomène de ces dernières
années les spice girls ont entrepris une
tournée en france première étape
marseille les fans étaient dans tous
leurs états hier soir yannick aroussi
vincent descendre dans ses chansons le
jour j est arrivé
il est grand temps de battre la grande
se mêlent pour aller voir les 7000 fans
déchaînés pour une première en france
les spice girls en concert
et un bain froid
d
23 millions d'albums vendus une carrière
fulgurante des clips un film et cette
tournée mondiale à guichet fermé
vous savez nous avons un public
formidable soutenu dès le début on ne
peut pas expliquer notre succès on fait
ce qu'on avait envie de faire on fait de
notre mieux et on est là aujourd'hui
nous avons beaucoup de chance car les
spice girls et leur public une histoire
d'amour visiblement partagé
la folie spice girl va souffler dès
demain à barcelone avant un retour très
attendu en france mais 19 mars à lyon
le couturier italien giorgio armani
interdit de défiler hier soir à paris la
préfecture de police estimait que les
conditions de sécurité de cette
manifestation qui se déroulait place
saint sulpice n'était pas assurée pas
suffisamment assuré en tout cas le
couturier furieux ils auraient décidé de
se transporter pour ce défilé à new york
finit par y at il dit plus calme la
suite des défilés du prêt-à-porter de
l'hiver prochain ce soir sonia rykiel
reportage nicole cornu langlois ans
drissa dans une architecture de cultures
et de futurs sonia rykiel fête ses 30
ans de couture 1968 elle jette un pavé
dans la mare détenus conventionnelle
montre ce qu'on a toujours cachée mais
les coutures à l'envers retire les
épaulettes invente des plus la porte et
sans soutien gorge des robes sans
tourner et sans but lucratif
elle se crée des rayures comme porte
drapeau et libère ainsi la femme de
toute entrave ce fut sa révolution
personnelle
trente ans après les filles de ces
femmes ont pris de la désinvolture
elles ont changé d'alluré mais garder le
même style
leurs petits-enfants décontracté n'ont
peur de rien
et leurs compagnons sont tous doux dans
leur costume de velours les
transparences et les décolletés son
voluptueux et prometteur
la femme équivoque et ambigu et
définitivement l'avenir de l'homme bon
anniversaire sonia rykiel
le cinéma dernières sorties de la
semaine une vraie blonde comme il dit
américaine qui fait d'une société
superficielles par ailleurs des
différents portraits d'acteurs de
mannequin à la recherche d'un premier
contrat du succès et quoi est ce succès
ne vient pas toujours
reportage au brier de l'air et christian
hottin si tous les chemins conduisent
les voyageurs à rome tous les artistes
rêvent de leur mon grand comme ça sur
une affiche à new york jets l'audition
avec un directeur de casting à 3h une
chance série dans cette ville où tout
semble née d'une illusion deux amis
acteurs pleins d'espoir mais serveurs
pour survivre attendent le jour où ils
feront craquer broadway devine qui a
décroché un rôle dans un seau caracter
conneries passion platine personnages
récurrents de rec jamais joué un somme
c'est par faire l'acteur croit 1600 $
par semaine et l'acteur à ce tarif
minable serbe a empoché j'étais diplômés
de cinéma j'avais même travailler sur un
film le stranger than paradise mais je
devais être serveur pour vivre c'était
d'ailleurs assez intéressant dans le
contexte de servir du fromage de
championnat 6 le film s'interroge sur
les difficultés de rester intègre dans
un monde où la mode le cinéma et la
publicité nous impose une image faussée
de la réalité
si bob accepte sans état d'âme un rôle
dans une série médiocre son ami jo ne
cède pas refusant de faire le jeu d'une
société superficiel on a un petit
problème à votre curriculum n'y a pas de
télé pas de pub et saufs
je m'intéresse pas trop de faire des
sauts en fait ah bon pourquoi ça bah ça
n'a rien à voir avec jouer la comédie en
tout cas pas comme j'envisage de le
faire c'est enfin c'est bidon c'est
juste stupide
eh bien il est évident que nous n'avons
absolument rien à nous dire et moi j'ai
bien aimé jouer ce personnage d'acteurs
qui doit se battre pour préserver son
intégrité morale
surtout parce que c'est une notion qui
semblent disparaître aujourd'hui dans le
monde du cinéma est en train de me dire
que tu es freine sur un thème grave une
vraie blonde est avant tout une comédie
particulièrement réussie faurie et l'on
se reconnaît finalement dans cette
recherche d'un bonheur authentique que
nous masquent souvent les apparences et
les conventions avant nous quitter le
rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi d'abord mohamed
al fayed à paris pour être entendu par
le juge d'instruction le père du
compagnon de diana n'est pas convaincu
par la thèse de l'accident il mène sa
propre enquête en parallèle conduite
sous influence de la drogue le phénomène
n'est plus marginal en france un projet
de loi pour être officialisée ce délit
comme il existe déjà
la conduite en état d'ivresse
dans quelques instants la météo de
sophie davant le point route valérie
maurice ce soir 20h50 envoyé spécial le
magazine de la rédaction avec entre
autres un reportage remarquable consacré
à l'intelligence animale demain 7h54
vérité pour cela voir recevra georges
sarre du mouvement des citoyens puis
demain soir vous retrouverez ici même
béatrice schönberg quant à moi je
retournerais dès dimanche 19h45 pour les
résultats des élections régionales
je compte sur vous bonsoir à libourne
dans quelques heures